[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is s and I'll be your
host
today so without further Ado let's dive
into today's episode and embark on a
great journey
together get ready to be engaged
entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about
bullying in
schools segment one can be about
understanding bullying we will Define
bullying as the repetitive International
and harmful behavior that involves an
imbalance of power between the aggressor
and the
victim there are so many different forms
of billing we will discuss the various
forms of bullying including physical
verbal social and cyper bullying
highlighting their unique
characteristics and consequences we will
present statistics and research findings
to shed light on the widespread nature
of building in
schools segment two can be about impact
on individuals and
communities there are emotional and
physiological effects so we will explore
the the terminal impact bullying can
have on the mental health and well-being
of victims including increased anxiety
depression and even suicidal
ideation and there are academic
consequences so we will discuss how
bullying can negatively affect a
student's academic performance leading
to the de increase motivation attendance
issues and lower grades we will examine
the potential long-term consequences of
bullying such as difficulties in forming
healthy
relationship low self-esteem and higher
likelihood of engaging risky behaviors
segment three can be about factors
contributing to bullying in social
dynamics we will explore how social
hierarchies peer pressure and a lack of
empathy can contribute to the
perpetuation of bullying
behaviors in Home and Community
environments we will discuss how family
Dynamics Community norms and exposure to
violence can influence a child's
likelihood of engaging in or
experiencing
bullying and in a role of Technology we
will examine the rule of technology in
bullying including the rise of Cy
bullying and the challenges it presents
for school and parents in segment four
we have strategies for prevention and
intervention in school policies and
programs we will discuss the importance
of implementing
comprehensive anti-bulling policies and
evidencebased
prevention programs within
educational institutions in empowering
bystanders we will explore the role of
bystanders in preventing and intervening
in Bowling situations emphasizing the
importance of fostering a culture of
empathy and support and in support
systems we will highlight the
significance of providing resources and
support for both victims and
perpetrators including conselling
Services peer mentoring and restorative
justice
practices the consequences of bullying
may also develop physical symptoms like
headaches or stomach aches in extreme
cases it it can lead to self harm or
Suicidal Thoughts on the other hand
bullies themselves May face negative
consequences such as disciplinary
actions social isolation and
difficulties in forming healthy
relationships in the future schools pray
a crucial role in preventing and
addressing bullying
incidents creating a safe and inclusing
environment is essential to promote
positive social interactions among
students implementing
comprehensive anti-bullying policies and
the programs can help raise awareness
educate students about the consequences
of bullying and provide them with
strategies to prevent and intervent in
buling
situations teachers and staff should
receive proper training to identify and
address buling
effectively it is crucial to ensure that
victims feel supported and that
appropriate disciplinary actions are
taken against the
perpetrators additionally fostering a
culture of empathy respect and kindness
within the school Community can
contribute to reducing instances of
bullying promoting positive behavior
encouraging students to stand up against
bullying can create a collective
responsibility for maintaining a safe
and inclusive
environment furthermore involving
parents in Guardians and anti-bullying
efforts is
vital schools can organize workshops or
informational sessions to educate
parents about the science of bullying
how to support their children and how to
collaborate with the school to address
bullying incidents
effectively technology can also play a
role in competing bullying schools can
Implement monitoring systems to detect
and address cyber bullying as well as
provide resources and support for
students who experience online
harassment parental involvement is
instrumental in combating bullying by
actively engaging in conversation with
their children and promoting a culture
of respect and empathy at home parents
can reinforce the values of compassion
and
tolerance Community Support including
the involvement of local organizations
and mental health professionals can
provide additional resources and
guidance for both the victims and
perpetrations of
bullying equipping students with the
tools to stand up against bullying is
crucial empowerment programs that
encourage empathy conflict resolution
and assertiveness can can play a pivotal
role in creating a supportive School
environment promoting open
communication channels and creating safe
spaces for students to express their
their concerns without fear of
Retribution is equally
important bullying in schools is a deep
rooted issue that demands immediate
attention and concerned efforts from all
stakeholders by fostering a culture of
empathy implementing comprehensive
anti-bullying policies and equipping
students with the tools to stand up
against harassment we can pave the way
for a more compassionate and inclusive
educational environment let us work
together to ensure that every child has
the right to learn and grow grow in a
safe and nuturing space free from the
shadows of fear and
intimidation verbal bullying means that
it involves name calling teasing or
using hurtful language to be little or
humiliate the
victim physical bullying means physical
aggression such as hitting kicking or
pushing is a direct form of bullying
that can cause physical harm and
emotional trauma
relational bullying is the this type of
bullying is characterized by social
manipulation exclusion or spreading
rumors to damage the victim's
relationship and solar social standing
and cyper bullying can be with the rise
of digital communication cyper bullying
has become the increasingly prevalent
involving the use of electronic devices
to s threatening M messages spread
rumors or publicly humiliate the victim
in the effects of bullying the
physiological impact can be as the
victims of bullying often often
experience increased levels of anxiety
depression and low self-esteem loading
to long-term pH physiological
consequences that can persist into
adulthood in the academic impact we can
say that bullying can significantly
affect a student's academic performance
leading to decreased motivations
absent and an overall decline in
academic achievement and in social
impact we can say the children who are
bullied May struggle to form trusting
relationships leading to feelings of
isolation and difficulty in developing
healthy social skills
prevention and intervention strategies
we have creating a safe environment and
here we can say that establishing a
culture of respect and inclusivity in
schools can help can help prevent the
occurrence of bullying and in
educational programs we can say that
implementing educational programs that
focus on empathy conflict resolution and
social emotional learning that can help
students
develop a deeper understanding of the
impact of their
actions after all I can say that let's
be strong towards building a future
where empathy and compassion Prevail and
where every student feels valued
respected and
safe thank you so much for joining us on
this episode of high school memories
it's been an incredible journey and
we're so glad you came along for the
ride
until next time take care
[Music]
bye